Here's something nobody wants to hear.
You're not unlucky. You're not cursed.
You're emotionally stuck at the age when
your biggest trauma happened. And until
you admit that, you'll keep living the
same year over and over. Think about it.
You rage quit jobs when criticized. You
give the silent treatment instead of
communicating. You're still having the
same fight you had with your parents,
except now it's with your boss, your
partner, or that barista. When something
goes wrong, what's your first thought?
If it's about what someone else did to
you, congratulations. You've identified
your emotional age. That explosion over
minor inconveniences. That's not about
the spilled coffee. It's about feeling
unseen, unheard, the same feeling from
when you were seven. But here's the
beautiful truth. Growing up isn't about
getting older. It's about getting
honest. Your stuck patterns are just
unhealed wounds in a three-piece suit.
They're not your fault, but they are
your responsibility. And that
distinction, that's where your power
lives.